la vedette la star
le héros 18 selvi le soft sera de bada
la décoration c'est essentiel ah oui là
pour se promener dans les rues de rabat
ce composant fois miquel
depuis des siècles base assez fier de sa
race bovine et pour cause le cheptel est
certes réduit 8 mille têtes environ
mais c'est du très haut de gamme ils
sont une dizaine d'éleveurs avoir
conservé des méthodes traditionnelles
à l'arrivée ça donne une viande goûteuse
persillé comme disent les connaisseurs
laloyaux se vend autour de 150 francs
qui l'on sait pas donner donner mais
n'allez pas dire ici que ça ne les vaut
pas sage actionnaires de la viande aux
bonbons delà il pense et on y lit à
notre siècle quand très épais ce genre
d'événement est un bon coup de promotion
pour un produit local
mais c'est aussi et surtout un moment
important de la vie de la commune ont
bien goûter ici une certaine
convivialité défaite comme ça c'est ce
qu'il faut voir
est-ce que c'est peu c'est pas seulement
des animaux pour la sacrifier tout mais
on va les manger on va en parler on va
revenir l'année prochaine on va on va
discuter les gens se reparlent de sa
guide important mais revenons un peu à
nos vedettes ses belles bêtes à la
magnifique robe grise elles vont être
examinées sous toutes les coutures par
un jury qui va récompenser son éleveur
et puis et puis comment ça va se
terminer pour elle la journée ah ben ça
va se terminer très mal parce que ils
vont aller aux abattoirs est collé
c'est aussi à cela qu'on reconnaît une
vraie star un destin tragique une belle
mort dans la fleur de l'âge